in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Ryan
and Melanie are with us hey guys how are
ya hi there welcome better than I
deserve good good to have you guys
welcome where're you from
we're from Montgomery Alabama very cool
and here to do your debt-free scream we
are I love it and how much have you paid
off fifty one thousand five hundred and
twenty six dollars and nine cents now I
count it that's good and how long did
that take fifteen months very good and
your range of income during that time it
was 113 to 120 very good okay what do
you guys do for a living well I work in
human resources I'm a recruiter for a
construction company cool and I'm in
property and casualty insurance very
good very good
fun fun so what kind of debt was the
$52,000 and half of it was my student
loans from college mhm
sixteen thousand was a finance car that
we actually drove that's out here it's
not financing right five thousand credit
card debt and a sixty five hundred
dollar medical bill very cool so you're
kind of normal yeah a little bit
everything and just bopping along how
long y'all been married almost two years
almost two weeks to uh our internship so
shortly after you got married then
something happened and you decided to
get on this what happened what happened
was we went through premarital
counseling and it didn't really talk
about finances and Ryan
oh yeah Ryan's like where's the
financial part we need to know about the
finances and so he found FPU and that
was the be end of story n' it's been
going ever since and we're totally on
board and love it Wow
so so it was that simple we got we got
to have this part figured out to be
married right and there's a class let's
go to the class and there we go well on
our wedding day our worship leader who
actually played the music at our wedding
was like hey you guys gotta do this FPU
thing and I was like okay well let's
sign up so we took it in January
throughout the course of the summer the
church actually went through the
momentum program where everyone yeah
went through we called it Unchained at
Frazier
Yesi and Montgomery and we actually
coordinated that fall oh why don't I get
twice in a year and now we're gonna
leave legacy journey starting in
February
very cool thank you very nee you'll love
legacy journey oh man this is fun
will congratulate great way to start
your marriage just like that yeah yeah
but what about the worship leader says
you ought to take this and didn't give
it to you as a gift suggestion that's
okay we'll give marred time later it's
great you guys so it sounds like it's
all easy and you just signed up you just
did it but it's not 15 years 15 years 15
months felt like 15 years was that had
to be tough it was what was the hardest
part of getting out it I'm actually not
going anywhere not doing anything not
spending money on food wearing same
clothes for two years and my belt just
started just wear you know these seams
there I actually brought a visual aid
here to show of all the different books
but I bought a book that either you
wrote or Thomas Stanley or rabbi lap and
or Robert Morris you know I read those
books and just kept intense and
financial peace lasts for nine months or
nine weeks and then after nine weeks you
know what do you do you don't have
support groups so I just kept reading
kept using every dollar kept checking
the budget having our budget committing
meetings just to stay intense so we're
just as intense now as we work two years
ago that looks like maybe I'm look at
that stack of books out there on the
table is that like 20 books it's 30 and
it's about half feet tall thirty okay
yeah that's pretty cool that's a great
great picture that's fun well you
learned a lot obviously by doing that
and you mean you but you got a master's
degree in personal finance now after all
that you are you are whole completely
qualified to be a coordinator
overqualified but okay in my finance
class in college okay okay so that guy
kind of set it off then like six years
ago yeah very cool well so what do you
tell people with all this knowledge and
all this experience that the key to
getting out of debt is I just have to
work together I mean if you're married
you have got to be on the same page and
for us it you know since we started our
marriage off that way it just kind of
came naturally hmm
and we also it felt like a game like I'm
very competitive so it was like can we
beat the budget this month mmm
pay off more than we planned to pay off
and so that really kept us you know
motivated as well so and it happened
faster than we thought that well it
would what money you find whenever we go
again yeah it is just a game it's a
Monopoly game it's not like you're
hungry it's not like you don't have a
place to live you're not homeless you
know you're not shoeless it's not
anything like that so there's an it's
all once is really what it comes down to
so it's a game what do you want right
what do you want most I wanted to be out
of debt and funding retirement have an
emergency fund more than we wanted to
continue living the way that I did when
I was single before we met so yeah and
to be able to give we're excited about
that
know generosity played a huge component
you know we tie the entire time we did
this mm-hmm I was given two missions and
that's kind of what our you know future
plans are and to be able to give
generously for the kingdom that's what
it all comes down to mm-hmm
that's very good very good well done you
guys very proud of you you're heroes
well done I love that stack of books man
I gather to read like that you can do
anything there's nothing that holds you
back that's absolutely incredible
speaking of books we'll add one to the
stack and that's a signed copy of Chris
Hogan's number one bestseller retire
inspired which will be the next chapter
like you said to continue to build
wealth and and be in a position to
always give and and have outrageous
generosity around you so well done so
proud of you guys all right Ryan and
Melanie Montgomery Alabama fifty-two
thousand dollars paid off in 15 months
making 113 to 120 count it down let's
hear a debt free scream three two one
that's how it's done right
I love it I love it I love it
well done you guys very well done
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you can do this you know that
really is a message whether you've got
two hundred seventy thousand dollars in
student loan debt or 27 thousand well
you've got a fifty thousand dollar
income or $500,000 in the company